un objeto se mueve a lo largo de una
recta la siguiente gráfica nos muestra
la velocidad del objeto a lo largo del
tiempo para cada punto de la gráfica la
rapidez del objeto está aumentando
disminuyendo o ninguna de las dos
pausa en el vídeo y tratan de resolverlo
muy bien hagámoslo juntos en primer
lugar tenemos que asegurarnos de que
estamos leyendo esto con mucho cuidado
porque no nos están preguntando si la
velocidad está aumentando o disminuyendo
o ninguna de las dos nos están
preguntando si la rapidez está
aumentando disminuyendo o ninguna de las
dos nos están hablando sobre la rapidez
que es la magnitud de la velocidad
puedes pensar en esto como el valor
absoluto de la velocidad especialmente
cuando estamos hablando en una dimensión
de modo que aunque no nos están
preguntando sobre velocidad en realidad
también lo quiero responder para que
podamos ver cómo a veces se mueven
juntas velocidad y rapidez pero a veces
una puede estar aumentando mientras que
la otra puede estar disminuyendo así que
si nos fijamos en este punto
nuestra velocidad es 2 metros por
segundo la rapidez es el valor absoluto
de la velocidad que también será dos
metros por segundo y podemos ver que la
pendiente de la gráfica velocidad contra
tiempo es positiva por lo que nuestra
velocidad está aumentando y el valor
absoluto de la velocidad que es la
rapidez también está aumentando un
momento después nuestra velocidad
probablemente sea 2.1 metros por segundo
y nuestra rapidez también sería 2.1
metros por segundo eso parece
suficientemente intuitivo ahora tenemos
otro escenario si vamos a este punto que
tenemos aquí nuestra velocidad sigue
siendo positiva pero vemos que la
gráfica de velocidad contra tiempo ahora
tiene una pendiente descendente por lo
que nuestra velocidad está disminuyendo
por esta pendiente descendente y el
valor absoluto de nuestra velocidad
también está disminuyendo justo en ese
momento nuestra rapidez es de dos metros
por segundo y luego un momento después
probablemente sea 1.9 metros por segundo
muy bien ahora vayamos a este punto este
punto es realmente interesante aquí
vemos que nuestra velocidad la pendiente
de nuestra línea tangente sigue siendo
negativa por lo que nuestra velocidad
sigue disminuyendo qué pasa con el valor
absoluto de nuestra velocidad que es la
rapidez bueno si piensas en un momento
anterior a este estaba disminuyendo para
llegar a una velocidad igual a cero y un
momento después de esto aumenta para
tener una velocidad negativa
probablemente digas aumentando para
llegar a una velocidad negativa recuerda
que la rapidez es un valor absoluto de
modo que si la velocidad va de 0 a menos
un metro por segundo
la rapidez pasó de 0 a un metro por
segundo así que aquí está disminuyendo y
aquí está aumentando la rapidez pero
justo en este momento no ocurre ninguno
de los dos no está aumentando ni
disminuyendo ahora qué pasa con este
punto aquí en la pendiente de nuestra
gráfica de velocidad contra tiempo o la
pendiente de la línea tangente sigue
siendo negativa por lo que la velocidad
sigue disminuyendo
qué pasa con la rapidez bueno nuestra
velocidad sigue siendo negativa y se
está volviendo más negativa por lo que
el valor absoluto de la velocidad que es
2 metros por segundo se está
incrementando en este momento del tiempo
así que la rapidez en realidad está
aumentando y como puedes notar aquí hay
una diferencia ahora qué pasa con este
punto bueno aquí la pendiente de la
línea tangente de nuestra gráfica de
velocidad contra tiempo es igual a cero
justo en este punto así que eso
significa que nuestra velocidad no está
cambiando por lo que podemos decir que
la velocidad no cambia y si la rapidez
es el valor absoluto de la velocidad
bueno tampoco está cambiando así que
podemos decir que la rapidez tampoco
cambia por último pero no menos
importante este punto justo aquí la
pendiente de la línea tangente es
positiva entonces nuestra velocidad está
aumentando pero qué pasa con la rapidez
bueno aquí la rapidez es de dos metros
por segundo recuerda es el valor
absoluto de la velocidad
y el valor absoluto está disminuyendo si
avanzamos un poco en el tiempo por lo
que nuestra rapidez está disminuyendo
está disminuyendo a medida que nuestra
velocidad se acerca más y más a cero
porque el valor absoluto se está
acercando más y más a cero hasta el
próximo vídeo